[Music]
in 1920s
Oklahoma oage oil wealth had
exploded of course that brings in a lot
of people who want to capitalize on that
our film focuses on one Fage family the
Kyle
sisters these are girls who know their
Community they know who they are and
they knew where they come
from because of their wealth they were
systematically taking advantage of the
family bond between all of the sisters
is very strong it's really the
foundation of the
movie Molly loves being with her family
being a loving
sister but when the murders start
happening then everybody's paranoia
starts
Rising this blanket is a Target on our
backs trying to get rid of me aren't you
snake
those sisters took care of one another
when no one else does please send help
there's murder in a host AG the police
do nothing it's a powerful historical
movie about love and trust and of course
family you only thing we know is we have
each
other you're my wealth you know
[Music]
that